man je tiens vraiment à vous remercier
et remercier tous les intervenants
je pense qu'on a n'a pas franchi qu'un
pas technique
c'est très important pour moi c'est pas
de la technique juridique non plus qu'on
a voulu faire c'est véritablement pas
qu'on a franchi à la fois sur la con la
construction de la loi ça c'est une
première chose
et la deuxième chose c'est une manière
aussi de de signal qu'on envoie à
l'hexagone ou collectivement les pays
d'outre-mer beaucoup apporté et c'était
que cela je suis persuadé que ce texte
là beaucoup de parlementaires demandons
l'application du mot nationale donc on
va inverser et l'inversion comme disait
césaire en considérant qu'elle
s'épanouit seulement de législatif vers
l'outre-mer par des troupes et
canalisations hasardeuse que tu connais
parfaitement mais plutôt le génie
d'expression de la construction de la
loi qui se fait localement équipe est
aussi riche et apporter une contribution
à la bretagne à l'alsace aux autres moi
je pense que c'est ça la différenciation
advient ces agences est pas une question
purement institutionnels c'est par un
séparatisme politique c'est une prise en
compte
reconnaissant un état d'esprit de la
diversité que la diversité plus une
richesse qui handicape le raisonnement
vis-à-vis de l'outre-mer c'est plus
considérer l'autre mais a comme un
handicap où on veut compenser et des
données la main c'est faux ça n'a pas de
sens il faut d'abord que la france la
république
lesueur les publicains autonomisme
républicains considèrent très clairement
que ce genre de processus permet aussi
une politique de reconnaissance des
peuples eux-mêmes et ce en redonnant de
la personnalité de la reconnaissance de
l'intégrité la dignité à ces populations
que l'on aura de plus en plus de
cheminement pour aller contre ce qu on
dit qu notamment de très graves ces
instants-là de redonner de la dignité à
nos peuples me restituer le roux droit
de pouvoir créer c'est pas du
séparatisme et c'était que cet excellent
ça sort du cerveau à la fois d'un
parlementaire mais surtout de
personnalité locale je pense beaucoup à
une jeune hôtel qui s'appelle
saint-potache aubenas qu'elle a
construit ce texte là avec nous et
aujourd'hui ce texte bourré weasley dans
toute la france et je serai très heureux
et j'espère que ce sera seulement pour
dix ans président on a opté pour dix ans
pour respecter le droit mais que ça
permettra de conjuguer de pouvoir
travailler en toute fraternité pour
aller vers ce que césar a dit la
nouvelle humanité intégrant la
différence